so a new king has chosen to send you to
the Nights Watch
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
safer to travel more Lord smart more
than I can say for this lot get these
prisoners to work bring the girl need a
new cupbearer you're my queen I told you
I don't want it you are my queen I don't
want it you are my queen this is not
life when will he be as he was when Sun
rises in the West sets in the east when
the Seas go dry when the mountains blow
in the wind like leaves I never wanted a
crown you will always be my Queen
Daenerys how quick don't want it your
back
[Music]
thank you tell me what are you doing
cooped up in here when the weather
outside is so normal my ones brought a
jackass and a honeycomb into a brothel
[Laughter]
you serious you should consider yourself
lucky lease your balls won't freeze off
you take great defensive dwarf jokes but
love telling you new jerks why is that
because I have balls and you Denver if
you'll have me
[Music]
dracarys
I just want you to know
I wish do you ever look at someone and
wonder what is going on inside their
head let me smash please hey girl
you want some tail I'm ready I won't let
you down
you're not going but I'm better than
every other than no one you come with me
you die here yeah Negro that's all you
had to say and who has a better story
than brand the Broken Bow that's not so
much
[Music]
if the city surrenders they will ring
the bells and raise the gates please if
you hear them ringing the bells call off
the attack
[Music]
ZDNet I've got this you know I keep
telling everybody they should move on
and grow some do they let us there
[Music]
[Applause]